>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
IT’S BEEN AN AWFULLY LONG
WEEK.
THANK GOD WE ARE ENDING IT
TONIGHT WITH TWO PIECES OF
GOOD NEWS.
THE FIRST GREAT BRITAIN IS
AN INDEPENDENT COUNTRY AGAIN
AS IT HAS BEEN FOR MOST OF
THE LAST THOUSAND YEARS.
BREXIT HAS GONE THROUGH.
SO CHEERS TO OUR FRIENDS IN
THE U.K.
IN THIS COUNTRY, THE
IMPEACHMENT FARCE IS ALMOST
OVER.
THAT’S OUR GOOD NEWS.
THE PRESIDENT WILL BE
ACQUITTED.
NOW, WE KNEW THAT FROM THE
FIRST DAY, OF COURSE, WHICH
IS ONE OF THE REASONS THIS
WHOLE OVERHYPED CHARADE WAS
ALWAYS SUCH AN INSULTING
WASTE OF TIME.
NOW IT’S OFFICIAL.
EVEN THE WETTEST TRUMP
HATING REPUBLICANS IN THE
SENATE ARE THOROUGHLY SICK
OF THIS.
THEY WANT IT OVER.
AND, YET, BECAUSE ONCE
STARTED, NOTHING IN
WASHINGTON ENDS EASILY, THE
PROCESS CONTINUES ON LIKE A
GHOST SHIP.
HERE WAS THE SCENE ON THE
SENATE FLOOR TODAY.
[SHOUTING]
>> OH MY GOSH!
>> Tucker: THOSE ARE
ACTUALLY RETAIL DRUNK
SHOPPERS IN RETAIL STORES ON
BLACK FRIDAY.
SAME SICKNESS AT WORK.
MOBS OF DESPERATE PEOPLE
GRASPING AT TRINKETS.
SAD TO WAY.
LET’S TRY TO FIND THE ACTUAL
TAPE FROM THE SENATE.
[SHOUTING]
>> Tucker: NOPE.
ONCE AGAIN, RIGHT THEME,
WRONG VIDEO.
JERRY SPRINGER WASN’T REALLY
IN THE SENATE THIS WEEK.
BUT JERRY NADLER WAS.
CHECK OUT WHAT HAPPENED LAST
NIGHT WHEN CHIEF JUSTICE
ROBERTS ASKED PROSECUTORS TO
ANSWER A FINAL QUESTION.
NADLER AND ADAM SCHIFF RACED
TO THE PODIUM ALL BUT
ELBOWING EACH OTHER OUT OF
THE WAY TO GET ONE LAST
BLESSED MOMENT ON C-SPAN.
WATCH THIS TAPE AND ASK
YOURSELF IF YOU HAVE EVER
SEEN ANYTHING WITH LESS
DIGNITY.
>> COULD YOU PLEASE RESPOND
TO THE ANSWER JUST GIVEN BY
THE PRESIDENT’S COUNSEL AND
PROVIDE ANY OTHER COMMENTS
THE SENATE WOULD BENEFIT
FROM HEARING BEFORE WE
ADJOURN FOR THE EVENING?
>> JERRY, JERRY.
>> MR. CHIEF JUSTICE,
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE -- I
WANT TO BE ON TV.
NO, I DO.
THESE PEOPLE ARE BUFFOONS,
THAT CLIP REALLY WAS THE
WHOLE IMPEACHMENT FROM START
TO FINISH, AS FAR AS NARCISSISTI
DEGRADING POINTLESS.
THIS NATION DESERVES MORE
BUT THAT WOULD REQUIRE
IMPRESSIVE LEADERS.
AT SOME POINT MAYBE NEXT
WEEK WE WILL LOOK BACK ON
THIS WHOLE CHAPTER IN SHAME.
BUT FOR A FOR MORE DAYS AT
LEAST THE HYSTERIA WILL
CONTINUE.
IT WILL LIKELY INCREASE.
THE MEDIA CLASS JUST SEEM TO
BE FIGURING OUT TRUMP WILL
NOT BE REMOVED FROM OFFICE
BEFORE THE SUPER BOWL.
YOU OBVIOUSLY KNEW THAT
OBVIOUSLY.
THEY HAD NO IDEA.
THEY ARE LITERALLY STUNNED.
OVER AT MSNBC A PERSON
CALLED MARA GAY DECLARED
THAT IF THE RESULTS OF THE
LAST ELECTION AREN’T
NULLIFIED IMMEDIATELY
DEMOCRACY IS DEAD FOREVER.
THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A
MINUTE.
SHE CLEARLY HASN’T.
IT’S KIND OF HILARIOUS.
ACTUALLY.
WATCH HER TANTRUM.
>> WHAT’S ON TRIAL IS NOT
JUST DONALD TRUMP RIGHT NOW.
WHAT’S ON TRIAL IS THE RULE
OF LAW.
WHAT’S ON TRIAL IS OUR
DEMOCRACY.
I MEAN, WHAT A SAD, SAD
MOMENT AFTER, YOU KNOW, 300
PLUS YEARS OF DEMOCRACY AND
BY THE WAY TRUTH MATTERS.
I MEAN AS A JOURNALIST, I
JUST THINK THAT’S WHAT
SEPARATES US FROM RUSSIA,
FROM VENEZUELA.
IF WE DON’T STAND UP FOR
TRUTH NOW, IT WILL BE TOO
LATE.
IT WILL BE TOO LATE.
>> Tucker: AS A JOURNALIST,
OH, AS A JOURNALIST.
[LAUGHTER]
AND THAT WAS YOUR TIP THAT
MARA GAY ISN’T SOME FAKE
DEMOCRATIC STRATEGIST THEY
INVITED ON A CABLE SHOW LIKE
THEY OFTEN DO.
SHE IS IN FACT A MEMBER OF
THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
EDITORIAL BOARD.
NOT THAT IT MAKES HER A
JOURNALIST.
SHE IS STILL THE BEST THEY
CAN MUSTER.
PONDER THAT OVER THE
WEEKEND.
THE POLITICS EDITOR OF THE
ROOT.COM MEANWHILE TOLD
VIEWERS THAT NOW THAT DONALD
TRUMP STAYING IN OFFICE
UNTIL NOVEMBER, NOTHING CAN
STOP HIM FROM BECOMING AN
AUTHORITARIAN DICTATOR.
>> IMAGINE DONALD TRUMP
DECIDING SOME TIME IN JUNE
WELL I HAVE HEARD THIS
CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT A
WHOLE LOT OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS HAVE VOTED IN
CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE DECIDED THAT DURING
THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
CALIFORNIA HAS TO GO UNDERGO
EXTREME VETTING BECAUSE WE
CAN’T TRUST THEIR VOTES.
WE ARE GOING TO SHUT DOWN
VOTING IN A STATE.
THIS IS LITERALLY THE KIND
OF THING HE WILL DO NOW.
>> Tucker: GOT THAT?
TRUMP IS, QUOTE LITERALLY
GOING TO CANCEL THE ELECTION
IN CALIFORNIA.
OUR BIGGEST STATE.
OKAY JASON JOHNSON.
LET US KNOW WHEN HE TRIES.
PEOPLE LIKE JOHNSON ARE
SAYING THINGS LIKE THIS
BECAUSE THEY ARE SO SHOCKED
THEIR BRAINS NO LONGER WORK.
THEY REALLY THOUGHT TRUMP
WAS GOING TO BE FIRED AT THE
END OF IMPEACHMENT.
THEY THOUGHT A FIVE MINUTE
PHONE CALL ABOUT HUNTER
BIDEN’S CORRUPTION WOULD BE
ENOUGH TO UNDO AN ELECTION
THAT 136 MILLION PEOPLE
VOTED IN.
LIKE A CREEPY OLD MAN IN A
PORNO THEATER THE PRESS AND
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ALLOWED
THEIR FANTASIES TO OVERSTRIP
REALITY.
THEY ARE ABOUT TO BE SHOCKED
BACK TO CONSCIOUSNESS VERY
SOON.
THE IOWA CAUCUSES ARE JUST
THREE DAYS FROM NOW.
BERNIE SANDERS IS LIKELY TO
WIN THERE HIS ONLY REAL
RIVAL IS A MAN WHO SHOULD BE
HAVING DINNER AT 4:30 AT
GOLDEN CORRAL.
PARTY LEADERS DON’T WANT
EITHER ONE OF THEM SANDERS
OR JOE BIDEN.
THEIR PLAN, THE PLAN IN
WASHINGTON IS TO FORCE
VOTERS TO BACK MICHAEL
BLOOMBERG A BILLIONAIRE
KNOWN FOR SCREAMING OUGHT
PEOPLE WHO DRINK THE WRONG
SODA.
NONE OF IT SEEMS VERY
APPEALING.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS IN
TROUBLE ABOUT TO COLLIDE
WITH ITSELF.
THAT DIDN’T NEED TO HAPPEN.
IF DEMOCRATS HAD JUST SPENT
THE LAST THREE YEARS TO I
DON’T KNOW A CREDIBLE PLAN
TO LOWER HOUSING CRISIS.
MIDDLE CLASS WAGES OR FIX
THE STUDENT LOAN CRISIS THEY
MIGHT WIN THE ELECTION YOU
THEY DIDN’T DO THAT EASY WAY
OUT.
WASTED ENERGY ON WILD
CONSPIRACIES ABOUT RUSSIA
AND UKRAINE AND WHILE THEY
WERE DOING THAT THEIR
UNHAPPIEST MOST ENERGETIC
ACTIVISTS FORCED THEIR
CANDIDATES TO TAKE LUNATIC
POSITIONS ON ABORTION, GUNS,
RACE, GENDER, CLIMATE.
YOU HAVE NAME IT.
POSITIONS WAY OUT OF
MAINSTREAM EVEN AMONG
DEMOCRATS.
IT ADDS UP TO A DISASTER.
AND THEY KNOW IT’S A
DISASTER.
THAT’S WHY THEY ARE SO
UPSET.
THE GOOD NEWS IS AS AWFUL
AND STUPID AS IMPEACHMENT
WAS, IN THE END, IT HURT THE